As I'm taping this right this right now, there's
a massive fire burning about 70 miles north
of here in Ventura County.
As of a few minutes ago it had already burned
over 50,000 acres and over 30,000 homes have
been evacuated.
I'm sure by the time you see this video those
numbers will go up significantly.
Here in Los Angeles there's soot flying around
everywhere and there's a dark grey haze and
a deep smell of smoke.
I just walked my dog for literally 2 minutes
and not only couldn't I see all the way down
to the end of the block because of smoke,
but my clothes stink right now.
Fortunately YouTube hasn't given us access
to their smell--o-vision feature just yet.
We just finished up our interview for this
week with Jessica Flanigan from the University
of Richmond and although we never edit for
content, we're probably gonna edit out a couple
coughs and hacks as the air quality in the
studio is pretty bad right now.
Ironically our interview had a lot to do with
public health, so stay tuned for that.
I don't mention any of this for pity for me
dealing with some soot and smoke today as
much as how things can be put into perspective
pretty quickly.
Of course a quick perusal of Twitter allowed
me to see people saying California was burning
because of its leftists sins and others saying
it's burning because of global warming and
lack of regulation.
Yes, even natural disasters are political
these days.
As we're in the midst of the holiday season
perhaps let's try to be a little less political
as we run out 2017.
The spirit of the season is about joy and
giving, not fighting and bickering, and it
seems we do the latter two a lot more often
than the former two these days.
The people being affected far worse than me
by these fires are on the left and the right,
they're pro-choice and pro-life, they're black
and white and Christian and atheist.
It's not just good ideas that can bring us
together, but also bad events, so let's not
make them worse with an extra helping of hate.
I'm gonna try to be a little less partisan,
a little more open and a little less political
as the year comes to an end.
I think I do a pretty decent job of being
fair and open minded in general, but a touch
more of those traits never hurt, especially
around holiday time.
Politics is important, but it isn't more important
than finding some room in your life to be
grateful, decent and tolerant.
My challenge, if you're up for it, is to perhaps
try being a little more tolerant yourself
in the spirit of the season.
I know you're intellectual opponents and sometimes
even friends and family members often won't
make it easy, but I think it'll be worth the
effort as we wind down this crazy year.
Whether we like it or not, we're in this thing
together and perhaps putting out some brush
fires now will spare us from some major fires
in the future...